welcome to the new class here at the
Chess Club and we have new place to
teach which is good this is an endgame
class that will have every Tuesday we're
going to try to talk about practical end
games more than theoretical end games
we're actually going to show end games
instead of end games that didn't happen
while showing games that did happen what
I'd like to do throughout the lecture is
talk about things that are important in
the end game especially if they're
different than what you would expect at
an opening or middle game so probably
the most important things I'll say
before the lecture and then when they
happen in the games I'll mention them
your King has to be more active in the
endgame than in the opening or middle
game don't tell that to Steinitz but in
the opening you want your King to be
safe and if you just hear from my
camera's lecture you'll notice his
opponents can usually wasn't very safe
in fact I wasn't sure about that but I
had a long discussion about it with
Laurence Olivier and Dustin Hoffman and
they assured me it wasn't safe so moving
your King up in the end game is very
important also having passed pawns is
important more important than the
opening because past pawns and queening
pawns is usually how you win and also of
importance is the activity of your rook
in the opening usually the rooks are in
the corner and they're not doing very
much in the endgame rooks are much
better than minor pieces in fact I would
say the first 15 to 20 moves of the game
probably Knights or bishops are better
than rooks and the last 20 moves of the
game the rooks just dominated now here
was a game I had a few years ago against
a feed a master stamina I was black this
looks pretty drawn and the reason it
looks pretty drawn is that it's pretty
drawing okay this should be a draw if
both sides play well we have the same
number of pawns same number of bishops
and same number of rook
now the reason it's probably better to
have black not that the computer would
agree is that black has a pawn majority
on the kingside which could possibly get
him a passed pawn whereas it's hard for
white to do that on the queenside
because white has doubled pawns okay so
I started with g6 I want to push my king
side puns up route to d4 h5 okay so I'm
advancing on the side I have more more
pawns Kappa blanket would be proud of me
b5 now B vibe makes a lot of sense
because white wants to trade his double
pawn and give me a week pawn for example
if I just take the pawn it looks like
it's hanging right okay now how does
white win back his pawn what does he do
don't I'll raise your hands and ones
anyone sees this pawn here rook rook b5
eventually I read before there's no
defense to route b5 and then he'll have
two-to-one on the Queen side and you
won't have any doubled pawns so that
would be nice
I don't want him to end up ons so I
played Bishop b6 attacking his rook now
if his rook moves up and down maybe I
will take that b5 pawn because maybe his
rook can't go to b4 but he played rook
a4 and now if i take on b5 obviously
he'll play rook before again and now i
play a 5 and now he's made a little
positional mistake because my bishop is
really fantastic now okay so before i
think is forced eventually otherwise he
can't move his pawns forward and i play
king d6 basically his Queen side pawn
structures impotent as far as moving
forward and gaining a passed pawn I have
total domination of the c5 square his
pawn majority is not very important also
my King could become more active than
his King and I've really shut down his
rook he can't play rook to d4 check so
now black has an obvious advantage my
[ __ ] is better than his my majority can
move forward
and his majority I'm just going to
attack with my king rook and Bishop okay
he played rugby Tzu which is really
passive I think he wanted to play rook
to d2 check
I played King c7 can somebody tell me
why I play King to c7 it sort of goes
against the rule of activating your king
but what other piece was i interested in
activating yes Elliot the rook on BA
wants to move either to this open file
or perhaps this open file but I can't
move my rep now cuz my b7 pawns attack
so I defend it and now I'm ready to play
something like Rick hey Rick a3 he
played Bishop e4 which i think is a
mistake because now my rook gets active
and now he has to defend his c3 pawn
which he does and I advance my majority
and yeah once I play Bishop c5 and b6 he
doesn't really have a majority on the
Queen side it can't move my rooks more
active than his and my pawn majority is
becoming active and let's go back if I
want to explain King g7 to you obviously
if I play g5 he just takes it if I play
out four he also takes it so the way to
advance my majority is to play e5 e four
etc well don't be too quick if you play
e5 here which I didn't do now Bishop f7
attacks all of my pawns and then I
probably would have lost okay so since I
know he's going to play Bishop f7 I play
King e7 first and now I can play e5 and
his bishop can't do anything okay so I'm
advancing my majority and his majority
doesn't look very impressive and he
tries to activate his King and
unfortunately for him his King could
actually get in trouble and I played
rook AAA and actually the next was
pretty hard to find if you were black
and you could move again what would you
do it has to be to export and I said no
because they told me to
f4 is legal very good
better than some of them in my in
commerce class actually I have a
checkmating idea here I want to play
rook to c8 and then his king and then
play Bishop e7 and rook c5 checkmate
that'll teach him to move his king up in
the in the opening endgame whatever this
is called
okay so he played rook g2 and I was like
okay that doesn't stop my idea
rook c8 now if it was my move I would
play Bishop e7 and I think he would
resign because I think Rick c5 mate is
unstoppable
so he played g4 which was the point of
rook g2 he's trying to get counter play
now if I play the obvious Bishop e7
threatening rook c5 mate with advantage
what does he do
louder checks me here g5 check and now
when my King moves my pawn is hanging
and ecigs is available and so forth okay
however if you were here earlier in the
lecture I mentioned getting passed pawns
was good and now black can get lots of
passed pawns
so I played Rick d8 check forcing his
King away from my pawns and then I took
and played efore now I'm going to play
f4 and then I'll have to connected
passed pawns winning his Bishop is very
suspicious on a2 so somehow over the
last 10 moves I've advanced my majority
on the Kings side and his Queen side
majority nothing is happening is totally
blockaded and the rest is very easy
h5 f4 and he resigned because f3 is
coming and luckily most chess sets
nowadays have two Queens so that could
be advantageous in this position right
because I'm going to get two queens
possibly more Queens later okay this is
another game I played in 2009 I'm white
against a mere Gabriel he's rated
approximately 2200
sometimes he's over 22-hundred usually
he's a little under and I was white and
I'm squeezing squeezing squeezing now
white has an advantage because my rook
is better than his and more importantly
my Queen site majority is you know
pushing up the board so I'm going to
play b6 a5 a6 and have my usual two
connected past pawns
now if it was my move I would play rook
takes a 7 also good okay so my opponent
thought his best chance was to go into a
King and pawn ending
he played rook to d7 if I don't trade
rooks which is also good then at least
I'm not taking on a7 okay so I
calculated here should I trade rooks or
should I not trade rooks and I made the
right decision so we'll let the class
thing for a little while and then we can
vote you can either vote for trading
rooks not trading rooks or not pap you
cannon now you you've been missing a
while yeah I've had this before and
sometimes we can and wins by mistake
so yeah it happens so should white
flight rook takes rook or should white
move his rook away to safety and try to
win the rook and pawn endgame okay let's
vow it who says rook takes rook trade
rooks who says move the rook away don't
trade rooks then who says Buchanan yeah
love you can't beat that not trading
rooks the class for once is correct one
and only time rook takes rook the reason
is my pawn majority is very strong on
the Queen side but I can totally stop
his pawn majority now b6 does win
because my computer said so but I was
more interested in stopping his pawns
so I played king c3 and when I traded
rugs I'd already figured everything out
I have a very simple plan okay I want my
King to go here and then I'll either
take this or take this while he's
running over here stopping me from
queening and if he plays e5 to stop King
f4 I'm going to play h3g for breaking
these pawns up then my kick is good
take this point fact when I put this on
my engine it only says White's plus one
then if you let it thing for like three
minutes
it's like plus fifty so it's like wait a
minute that plans pretty good but it has
to see it okay so he played a five
stopping my idea and I played h3 I got
to play h3 right away because if I play
King to d2 now he can play f4 and then
it gets a little dicey however if I play
h3 first which I did now f4 runs into g4
okay and now I'm going to have passed
pawns on both sides of the board and his
King can't split in half and have half
of the King go to each direction okay
also I'm assuming taking on f4 wins
without doing any analysis
this looks pretty winning so I guess
that four losses to everything okay so
he played King to c7 and he actually had
an idea and I did my idea and he did his
idea and now he realized if he didn't do
anything I would play g4 and win so he
did something very interesting he took
and played a5 giving me two connected
passed pawns and now we're going to vote
again we're going to vote should white
take on passant which you learned
earlier today in comers lecture or
should white keep those two connected
passed pawns
so analyze in your head a little bit and
see what the right answer is is there
jeopardy music we can play yeah
all right who says take on pasand
who says don't take on pissant hey we
and who says Buchanan you always vote
twice the answer is if I don't take on a
pissant he'll play a4 a3 a2 a1 and if I
don't want to do that and where my king
over here then you'll play f4 III then
he'll have pawns on both sides of the
board so by taking on Poisson I
eliminate all of those issues and now I
play the easily winning move g4 I
thought you would know
I know G for now if it's my move
I can play G anything and win GF g fiber
GH so he has to take it I take and he
took this way if he plays h4 I'm just in
time wasn't that lucky the good player
is always lucky okay and then I'll clean
my Jeep on so he played hg and for some
reason he didn't resign here he played
out a long time okay so f4 would be a
blunder that would that would draw but I
didn't do that
okay and now every legal move wins that
right one two three yeah I have seven
legal moves and they all win that's good
for me you have four wins right they all
win okay he I played f3 never playoff
three and then then f4 now he resigned
because if he moves his king either
direction then I go here and these are
my next four moves then they can't be
stopped and I probably pro to a queen
yeah right you could pre move that so so
after half four he resigned so the King
upon ending was winning I could distract
his King going one way and my king went
the other way this is actually a very
important concept so one thing I want to
show you even though I don't know how to
show you new positions new board window
that's not very helpful there's no new
position yeah yeah that's why you chest
I mean chest base is great so you can
imagine a position where black has pawns
on a 7 and h7 and that's it and white
has pawns on D 2 and E 2 in the opening
you'd probably want the center puns but
in the end game if you're pushing your a
and H bonds
I don't think White's King can go both
ways in solve them so outside passed
pawns on the outside of the board are
very good in the endgame not only do
they beat Kings they can beat other
pieces if you're pushing an a pawn and
your opponent's using a knight to stop
it that Knights not going to go to the
side of the board so outside pawns are
very good chess base not so good outside
pawns good and also it's not user error
that's the important thing to remember
I don't know okay now this is one of my
favorite games as long as my opponents
not watching this lecture that I may get
more death threats than I usually get oh
yeah I push ctrl F okay so this was
played in the last round of a tournament
in Ohio and I had three and a half out
of four my opponent had four out of four
so I needed to win now earlier in the
game I missed a very simple tactic
winning a bishop and then he would have
resigned but I didn't know that I missed
it now if you're watching the Anand
Carlsen match there was a game where
Carlsen blundered horribly Anand missed
it and then following that move they
both saw that black was winning so it
was probably hard for an on the play
knowing that he missed an easy win I
didn't know I missed an easy wins I had
no trouble ignorance is bliss when the
game ended my opponents like well you
could have gone here I'm like twenty
Musa going I wouldn't resigned okay so
we got this ending which is obviously
winning right Julian Julian's like wait
a minute
shouldn't you agree to a draw here okay
now we don't agree to a draw because I
need to win to get first place I have
three and a half out of four and he has
four out of four so I need to win this
cam now Black's better because I can win
upon ray okay now my opponent I thought
played pretty well here he played f5 and
he's going to lose at least one or two
of his King side pawns so he might as
well mess up my pawns now Bishop takes
pawn would be terrible can people to do
it because he takes and my F pawn is
pinned and if I lose all of my pawns I'm
not going to win okay so I can't play
that I didn't want to play this taking
here because then I have the worst pawn
structure ever and he can take the pawns
it will Bishop here Bishop here Bishop
here and probably I'll have like an
extra double DEFCON and I'll never win
so instead I played King g7 I'm still
going to take his King side pawns but I
want to keep some pawns of my own that
aren't doubled okay once again he played
well he played g4 and he wants to trade
all the pawns off that I'm not going to
for example if I take this takes takes
takes takes tanks I have a zero point
zero percent chance of winning okay
unless I'm playing ken watts
then it's 0.001 okay no I'm kidding I
would just went what unclear okay so
after g4 I played H takes G for Ray and
he took on g6 and again with the doubled
pawns I don't have much chance to win or
any chance to win so I played King tapes
I want to play f5 then I have chance to
it again unfortunately white jazz plays
h5 check which is what he played I play
King f6 because I don't want to lose my
F pawn if I do I have no winning chances
and now he blundered horribly which is
good because I was playing him okay in
this position black doesn't really have
any winning chances but instead white
decided to draw immediately instead of
draw in the slow fashion he played king
d3 king e4 which is all good and now he
blundered with h6
and when he played h6 he miscalculated
this position white can make any move
and draw because if I move my King to g5
he plays Bishop takes f7 if I move my
King here he just plays h6 and if I move
my King back he'll play King f5 and I
just there's no winning chances for
black instead he decided to draw
immediately and get the first place
although he was miscalculating a little
bit you
am i playing for the loss yeah but f5 h5
f5 yeah these pawns aren't very strong
because there's these pieces here to
stop them so there's nothing I can do I
can't like push them all
for example f4 and then here draw greed
no who's playing for the win
why why is what we'll explain why why
black is better it is when I play King
you - King f3 it's so closer ok so what
so King f6 that's what you're playing
King h6 that makes more sense over right
ok here I'm assuming after Bishop takes
b7 I'm a pawn up for nothing maybe that
was better
alright an white wins now it's a draw
but baby [ __ ] takes b7 white wins maybe
maybe for his wedding ok so in this
position if after the correct King takes
g6 we got this position my opponent
didn't want to draw in 20 or 30 moves he
wanted to draw now so he played h6
calculating all the way to the draw
except you missed one little thing
missed it by that much right Don Adams
agrees I played the obvious king g6 and
he played the move he was all ready to
play and he was all ready to agree to a
draw h7 and he thought the game would go
King age 7
Bishop f7 draw agreed but instead I
played that move only Julian can see
well let's call on somebody else black
to play and win overlooked by my
opponent
g5 check is closed f5 check that's what
you meant
yeah and now when you move this King
away
I play King takes h7 and I got my two
connected pass pawns
now I wouldn't resign here and I
wouldn't think of resigning here but he
was distraught over f5 tracts thinking
the game was going to be a draw now
realized he's lost and he resigned and
then they showed me like 30 music I
could have want a piece instantly but
missed it okay so that was actually good
revenge because the player in question
here he beat me in the last round of the
Kings Island open a tie for first when I
wanted to tie for first
why don't I tie for first and that was
the tournament we're on the way to the
tournament I hit a deer and then after I
hit a deer what did I say in Homer
Simpson's fashion oh of course of course
so that was terrible not only did I hit
a deer but I lost in the last round of
this guy this tournament was better I
wanted I hit no deer okay
of course okay the next one is a very
suspicious game
it's against Grand Master Eric Hansen
from Canada who was not a grand minister
at the time his international master and
we got this position and I was like oh
boy what an easy win okay and no win is
easy
let's show you're playing a grand master
they put up a fight I mean like you
could be let's say 20 to 70 and plus 100
and hang mate and one you could be 20 to
30 and you have an extra rook at an
ending and it's only a draw so the
grandmasters are tough did you get any
of that no oh well that was making fun
of Doug Eckhart and Matt Larson in the
same sentence those were games I was
losing back-to-back but I got 100 of two
because grandmasters are tricky okay I
learned chess on the streets from Run
DMC so this position I thought would be
a very easy win so I played quickly
always a good idea right you watching
this Owen and I won and I was like yeah
I'm great I want to play fast it was
easy then I looked with an engine and
the engines like no no no I'll every
move uh blunder ok you hear me talk to
Julian ok so he played rook a
seven and I'm like man to past pause oh
boy so I played rugby one and then I
started moving my pawns up and everybody
was happy okay
and then in this position I played f3
double question mark who would have
thought f3 could be a bad move okay
and the way to win here for black is
well I thought everything won but why
did Black has one way to win rook check
obviously has to defend his pawn f3 he
has to stop my pawn King d5 now he has
to decide whether he wants me to take
his pawn or not and here if he checks me
then he's moving away from my for my F
pawn so I get a tempo I get to go here
and again he has to go back but he's not
threatening to play at c7 now so now the
win is just technical and I get a tempo
by playing king d5 and rook takes losses
because I check his King away to the a
final and this is a very easy win
because his King doesn't participate so
that was winning that was the only way
to win I thought everything won
so I played f3 and I calculated
everything and he played what I
calculated if he had played not what I
calculated and game probably didn't draw
so he played c7 double question mark
okay and we were both playing quickly we
both thought I was winning and you know
no problem and I'll go back and show you
how you should have drawn I played f2 he
stopped it from queening of course if he
Queens I just check then he was his king
and I just take it and now I'm ready to
Queen and with a queen and upon I can
beat a rock usually okay so he played
instead rook there Knight Queen anyway
and now he resigned because irrespective
of whether he Waltons in check and then
if he Queens I win his Queen hooray
I just thought that was pretty easy I'm
a pawn op I'm cleaning everything's
great then my computer says f3 double
question mark and now he should play
rook FA attacking my pawn
I defend it and now this position should
look familiar to you because of the
other variation where I play correctly
this rook is here and this King is here
in that position as a win is a win for
black for black but now he plays king c5
not King d5 the difference is he can go
to d6 if his Kings on b5 and my rooks on
c1 he's never going to play King d6
unless his King turns into a knight okay
now if I play for example rook check he
plays King d6 oh and yeah this is
transposing into the ePHI variation
which is and this is just a draw F to
work here draw and just okay I guess if
you really want to draw right away Carl
Bohr style you just take okay and then
and then draw so it's funny this
position which I thought was an easy win
that I won easily had a double blunder
in it that's why we're as good as Magnus
and vichy we have double blunders in our
games too and then nobody notices them
and we're great yeah okay and
fortunately trade the computer on makes
you feel more silly so these simple end
games are very complicated the most
famous of which I'm sure you're all
familiar I'm probably boring you with
this knowledge you already have is the
game that Fischer played a rook and pawn
ending in he was completely drawn and
just played quickly and drew and the
guys like why are you playing so quickly
all it's a dead draw and then he was
shown I believe by Oman or he was
playing one that uses lost he just made
a one move blunder losing his opponent
didn't notice that they just played fast
and drew so these endings are
complicated and either if you think
they're simple they're not I'm sure he
was upset after the game when the
computer showed him that he should have
drawn after by my carelessness okay so
now we're going to have a vote because
voting is fun
first of all black is in check and
blacks going up otherwise f1 Queen then
FA Queen okay so this is just a normal
position black has a rook Bishop and
pawn for a queen would you rather have
white or black we have to think about it
it's hard right Elliot see people at
home were scratching their head in vain
to understand the situation okay who
says I'd rather have black and have the
rook and Bishop for a queen who says
they want to have the Queen and who says
we can't nobody be get that okay yeah so
this is obviously better for mmm for
black because black can't possibly lose
like has nothing to attack and white has
three isolated weak pawns that's not
good
those pawns could be captured especially
if I'm black because I want to capture
them it's hard to defend all three my
pawns are all defended and great okay so
I stopped check
and then I attacked his H pawn he
defended it I attacked his deep on he
defended it nice active Queen there and
I just move around having a lot of fun
winning his H pawn he couldn't save his
H Blancas my bishops on a dark square
and we just take all of his pawns and
there's no stalemate and he never can
check me yeah that was fun now if he
plays Queen g3 Rick g5 with advantage so
he played there yeah and now it's pretty
clear blacks better right so in this
instance a Queen's usually better than a
look at a bishop but when there's no
checks and there's no pawns to attack
then black has no losing chances fact
there's a lot of interesting positions
where Queen doesn't beat a rook and upon
a queen and upon don't beat a rook at
upon because the blockades this position
black had zero losing chances because
white had no checks and no pawns do
attack but black was winning because
white had all these weak pawns to attack
and it was easy to take them
and get past pawns so actually was
pretty simple simples good
okay last and least is my game with
Dennis now this is very interesting
because about four years ago I started
playing e4 and generally I was playing
d4 I move one and I was like it's time
to play e4 and then I could mix it up
and so today I play e4 and D for about
half the time now I'm playing Dennis
moniker OSIS who's an indiana player and
i've known him forever and this is at
the indianapolis open last round and i
was half a point behind the super GMS
because i played two of them and we drew
and they only played one of me so they
were playing each other in the last
round and they were drawing in five
moves and tying for first and i had to
win to tie for first a my opponents
about twenty three fifty plus tax
although don't underestimate accident
annapolis
they also been indianapolis so no it's a
little iffy and this is the tournament i
just got my car and I drove to
Indianapolis and a rock hit it on the
way and you can still see it because
that's that's Indiana for you okay I
have a lot of Indianapolis stories but
you know they're not really ready for
chess club they're they're more for like
you know if you want to cry all day okay
so anyway I was white and I was like
while I'm playing
efore now but I need to win this game
this is like an important game it's the
last turn I got tied for first so maybe
I should play d4 and I was like I'll
play E for I'm playing e4 and we got
this position obviously my style is very
boring now hear my opponent made an
error and he thought the game was over
he played Queen g8 and he offered me a
draw and he was thinking if I trade
Queens
that's a draw I agree with that if I
don't trade Queens he'll take my pawn on
hate so and be a pawn up I agree with
that too
so he was like Queen GA finally it's
equal well Queens uhit's a mistake
because I play Queen f5 now Queen takes
a two runs into difficulties after nine
g5
when you're in an endgame and there's
heavy pieces don't ever forget about
checkmate you can always get checkmated
whenever you want to it's always there
if you try to run away
King g8 your didn't run very far and if
you play Queen g8 that's even worse
because you're down a queen instead of
mated and yet to suffer okay and g6
loses for the same reason we play Queen
Shack and Knight f7 check mate okay so
after 9 g5 blacks losing so he didn't
play Queen takes a - well in that case
his move wasn't very good he actually
played the best move here
Queen e8 ok and now I played a shocking
move for me because it wasn't boring
okay and I remember I was at the Chess
Olympiad in 1990 in Novi Sad Yugoslavia
at the time and at that Limpy add the
British Prime Minister Margaret Thatcher
resigned she wasn't the only British
person who resigned a lot of their
players resigned - during Olympia
Nigel short was not happy he was a big
fat your fan okay there's some people
like evil what are you gonna do okay so
replacing Thatcher if I remember
correctly which I don't I'll be
corrected by all you historians in the
room was John Major now right anybody
I never heard John Major and there was a
British guy at that Olympia I didn't
know and I said what do you think of
this guy who replaced Margaret Thatcher
and he said I like him he's really
boring like me since I want a boring
politician and I was like I never
thought of it like that
okay so I try to play as boring as
possible okay and so this will shock all
of you but in this position I could feel
that Matt Larsen wanted me to play this
move even though I hadn't met him yet
it's hard to understand you lost not a
prediction I already gave it away
g4 of course because I have a King side
attack I have a pawn majority on the
Kings side I got to get my pawns going
I don't think my opponents going to move
his queenside majority is nowhere to go
okay so h6 giving himself some left
kingi to g5 r RR okay and again I can't
draw the game because that I don't tie
for first I get nothing takes takes yay
now I'm attacking and I went upon now
instead of continuing to attack I decide
making two Queens is a good idea because
I have to pass pawns
so I start moving my past pun
and he doesn't really do anything on the
Queen side so that's good for me because
I have to pass pawns he sacrificed his
Knight because he knew eventually the
pawn just go forward and win and he
thought he might have perpetual chat and
then he would draw the game costing me
lots of money terrible but unfortunately
as like two or three checks okay and
here you resigned whether he checks me
here here or here I play King g4 and I
could escape one of these ways and all
my pieces blockade although his King got
saved yay nice on a7 okay but because I
advanced my majority and got an attack
on the on the King side and his King ran
away I took the Jeep on now I had an
extra material and I could win with my
pawn majority again as kappa blanka
would say oh and if he would say it
advanced on the side you have the
majority
I had three against two so I played g4
g5 I won his Jeep on I trade it for his
other pawn all of a sudden I have to
passed pawns did black get an advantage
on the Queen side moving his pawns as
the Germans would say is shown things so
he got nothing okay he didn't make a lot
of Queen moves though that was very
exciting it looks like the king is
carrying a balloon it's floating him to
safety
right my comer exactly I took the words
out of your mouth
as per usual yeah so what have we learn
in the endgame practical end games like
the ones I showed you they're not the
ones in books where it's just King and
pawn against King and you triangulate
and you get
opposition there's always complications
and counterplay and more pieces on the
board but the same thing is always true
activates your king advance on the side
you have a majority push your passport
or rooks you can still give checkmate in
the end game when you get checkmated
it's embarrassing but it happens it
could even happen in Queen and pawn end
games with nothing else King upon
innings is tougher I've seen it but
getting made of adjusting in pawns it
happens but it's a rarity so I hope you
liked this endgame lecture it was
slightly longer than my cameras lecture
and almost as good okay so we'll see you
next week at the endgame lectures here
at the Chess Club and Scholastic Center
of Lester's
you